panic and Chaos
as crowds flee
and gunshots ring out in the Tunisian
resort island of jerber authorities say
an officer of a naval guard shot a
security guard before opening fire
outside the griba synagogue
the gunman killed and wounded several
visitors and police
before he was shot dead
attack happened during a Jewish
pilgrimage at Rieber one of Africa's
oldest synagogues
thousands of pilgrims travel to the holy
site every year
many come from Europe the United States
and Israel to take part in an event held
between Passover and shabbawat
although it's predominantly Muslim
Tunisia is home to one of North Africa's
largest Jewish communities
the griba synagogue has been targeted
before in an Al-Qaeda suicide bombing in
2002 21 people were killed
and in 2015 twin attacks in Tunis ensoos
killed dozens of tourists this attack is
happening at the beginning of the
touristic season of the summer and the
Tunisian authorities rely a lot on the
revenues of Tourism to face the growing
economic and financial problems they
don't want to have any impact on the
tourist touristic season
France and the United States have
condemned the latest shooting while
investigators try to determine the
motive for the attack Tunisian
authorities are calling it an act of
cowardly aggression rahila Mohammed
al-jazeera